il ya un an jour pour jour l'usiné
bridole s'embraser à rouen 9000 tonnes
de produits chimiques sont partis en
fumée un gigantesque nuage couvrait la
ville vous êtes dans mon jardin c'est
ici que le nuage est passé je suis à 2
km dans cet axe du foyer et donc ce
nuage a déversé sur le jardin des plus
d'hydrocarbures
les boules de celui des plaques de
fibrociment amiante et donc j'ai
retrouvé que je fait constater par
huissier
un an après ludovic lepage est toujours
amer voilà on est dans mon potager dans
lequel j'ai mis beaucoup d'amour tout
est fait avec des produits bio naturels
et des récupérateurs d'eau de pluie
voilà et ça pousse et ça poussait très
bien juste avant lubrizol d'ailleurs
c'était ma première année j'avais planté
mes graines et aux magies tout
fonctionne la nature est là et l'ubs
reason est venu déverser son vomi sur
tous ses produits comme des centaines de
sinistrés
ludovic lepage poursuivi leur idole en
justice je me sens d'attaqué à ne pas
les lâcher
même si ça a des conséquences ça demande
beaucoup de temps beaucoup
d'investissement
commencé à s'intéresser à la chimie et
puis et puis à l'industrie c'est
anxiogène c'est pas drôle hein certains
préféraient regarder une bonne série à
la télé mais je considère que les
citoyens doivent reprendre en main une
partie de leur destin on peut pas
laisser les industriels nous polluer
comme ça ce que je veux c'est une
punition sévère pour tous les
manquements de cette entreprise de leurs
voisins et de l'état qui n'a pas fait
son travail
alors que lubrizol est mise en examen
pour atteintes graves à l'environnement
et à la santé
les avocats des victimes et
l'association des sinistrés de lubrizol
ont annoncé attaquer l'état et lancer
une procédure en référé pour faire la
lumière sur les circonstances de
l'incendié
le premier message il est essentiel
c'est ce qui peut se résumer en un mot
la transparence des documents
fondamentaux n'ont pas été mis dans le
domaine public
on a saisi le juge en urgence de manière
à obtenir ces documents
c'est un tournant parce qu'on essaie
d'utiliser tous les moyens qui sont les
nôtres et qui existe dans le droit pour
aller chercher les différentes
responsabilités
il y a eu la mise en examen lui brise
hall dans l'enquêté pénale
et là on essaye de rechercher les autres
fautes ou les carence fautive qui
auraient pu être commises par ailleurs
simon gray carvalho président de
l'association des sinistrés de lubrizol
se réjouit de cette décision
on veut prendre notre destin en main on
veut plus subir on veut être acteur de
notre vie donc ça démarre par cette
procédure en effet au pénal donc nous
avons lancé déjà la procédure au pénal
donc c'est la continuité de notre
procédure c'est tout à fait normal et
logique qu'on attaque l'état
un an après l'incendié de lubrizol les
associations et les militants
maintiennent la pression malgré le
traumatisme est le sentiment d'être
oubliés les victimes refusent de lâcher
le combat est les riverains comptent sur
le référé contre l'état pour comprendre
un besoin selon eux pour tourner la page